hey guys justin here at Comic Con 2015
i'm talking with ryan peterson the brand
manager for rainbow six and great low
sixes is looking really good to show you
guys off of the san diego comic-con show
floor but you have this really nice up
here yeah you know we're really excited
to bring Rainbow six siege to san diego
comic-con into your point where it we're
not in the booth we're out a little bit
because we really wanted to bring our
experience to life so we have a really
great setup here where we kind of
brought the map from the first reveal
trailer to life we have a bedroom set up
to kind of show the close-quarter combat
that the game is but we have all the
wall shut off and stuff it's really cool
to kind of build that kind of experience
and this is a lot of people's first
chance to get to play the game to get to
try it out and you guys have kind of a
special way of going about this and san
diego comic-con is kicking that off how
does that work yeah yeah so this is the
grand revealing of the siege games this
is the first event in this competitive
tour that we're doing and we wanted to
bring at the san diego comic-con because
this is really a huge fan event and
since we haven't had a game out in a
while the intent was to really deliver
something for the fans and the siege
games is it's something a little bit
different it's not like the you know the
dedicated esports type of community will
let the community decide after the game
comes out once they play it if that's
what this game is but we wanted to make
sure that people had a chance to get
their hands on it because we know when
people play it and they get in there and
they're playing with a great team and
they're chatting and they're in there
really experiencing the new dynamics of
siege combat the fortifying packing they
have a great time with it so we wanted
to bring that on the road and the season
games allows us to do that we're finding
winners but there it's about team play
and got leaderboard play so it's high
score so you come if you by yourself
will pair you up Kim the team of five
like real your life matchmaking will
pair you up throw in you play a great
game you don't get a score you want get
back online and play again see it runs
it in a way where you get to have fun
and not really feel intimidated by
and so those teams what are they working
for what are they trying to win yeah so
if you make the top of the leaderboard
we will select you as a winner and we're
taking five guys so one team five guys
or girls who perform at the top and you
get a ticket to attend siege day so see
today is like our big launch event it'll
be on early October right before the
launch of the rainbow 60-page on october
13th and it'll be a celebration a
celebration of competition will bring
five winners from each of the events the
four events that we're going live also
the closed beta we're taking 10 windows
than that which is really any way to get
people to engage the beta and they'll
come together to this event will be
familiar faces there'll be some big
faces there'll be some really great
gameplay will be live streaming it and
everyone who wins it gets ticket city
nut and the way that you guys are
structuring the beta there's a
partnership you guys are doing with
child's play this year how does that
work yeah so actually working with extra
life and the charity partnership there
is actually it's really great these guys
a fundraise for the Children's Miracle
hospital network and we're just big fans
of what they do the impact that they've
had in the community they've raised
millions of dollars last year for
children hospitals they provide them
video games and entertainment to work
with their spirits and and really help
their betterment and their impact is
undeniable we know that we have a really
passionate community and passionate fan
base so we partner with them to raise
funds if you donate six dollars or more
you're you get a guaranteed access to
the closed beta you can go to the siege
gamescom website right now and sign up
for the wait list which doesn't
necessarily guarantee you if you do the
donation you get a key into it so I
think for us it's like the golden ticket
right because we're taking winners from
the closed beta and and the easiest way
to get in is to give back to the
community give back to the charity and
you get a guaranteed access to play and
all of that money all of those six
dollars that's 100% towards extra
lighter oh yeah yeah all for the
fundraising so you know you give the
money to schools benefit from it you get
access to play it you share the keys out
with your friends you get somebody then
you play the closed beta which starts on
September 24th you play for a high score
and then if you're entered in you get
chickens to come into that so I know one
thing that people were maybe a little
bit concerned about was with the Alpha
though this is a popular you have to
have five people playing with you the
matchmaking on that was maybe not quite
there but it's the outfit you know you
guys are still putting that together is
that kind of work better in the beta how
is that gonna
work yeah yeah and you know that's
that's a it's a great point because the
Alpha was awesome for us we learned so
much about the mechanics of the game
that that we got between can be worked
on it and you know you saw the outfit it
was pc only it was small so we we took
that some of our core fans some of the
guys that we've you know had play or old
games to give us a really great feedback
we're totally optimizing that for the
beta there'll be new maps new characters
new matchmaking that whole thing will be
nice and tight would be tons of new
experiences for people to play new modes
also we've already announced terrorist
hunt that'll be part of the closed beta
as well so there's a lot more variety so
and of course people here at San Diego
comic-con are gonna get that chance to
try it out first what's the next meet
Lex leg we're people gonna be able to
play it next yeah so at san diego
comic-con all week and then the next
event is our TX in austin so super
excited about that big big event for the
FPS community so we're really happy to
be to be partnering with them their
extra life will be on tour with us as
well so there'll be local extra life
charity workers who are coming with us
to auxin to austin and then we have
packs coming up next after that bull so
a lot of really fun opportunities in
ways that you can get to try out Rainbow
six siege and we're here at Comic Con
2015 if you want to hear more about
rainbow six or comic con in general stay
tuned to gamespot com
you